servus es geht und herzlich willkommen
zu einer runde 1 sieg etwas überzeugt
ist vollkommen nebensächlich
wir werden uns heute mit einem thema
beschäftigen was mich richtig krass
geflüstert und zwar malte von brücken
farms hat sich gezeigt
einfach so in einem video vollkommen
ohne einfach einfach so ist voll krass
ohne ankündigung
er schreibt er sagt nichts dazu zählt er
für seine schweine maske weg und
schmeißt die hinter sich und ich habe
mir das video vor
da dreiviertel stunde gesehen und ja ich
habe einfach gedacht das ist so krass
ich wirklich ich hab noch mehr noch
jetzt nicht wirklich so
besonders ihr laborierte gedanken dazu
gemacht und ich wollte einfach meinen
ersten eindruck damit euch teil weil
sich auch beschäftigt hatte ich schon
extrem viel brocken fans deswegen fand
ich natürlich krass und ich finde auch
überhaupt kein versteck oder falke darum
geht es überhaupt nicht wenn jetzt
direkt ab kenntnis mir scheißegal
hallo erst mal hallo erst mal mit dabei
sind dennis und also 3 und pascal
spielen gleich diesen beiden der
beschreibung hey ho könnt ihr euch gerne
anschauen und ja wie gesagt jetzt 103 4
stunde gesehen gebracht meinte kienast
alter aber okay irgendwie ist es auch
typisch putenfarm ist einfach was
vollkommen verspeiste das zu machen was
jeder andere youtuber hätte in welcher
technik jede andere youtuber hätte
irgendwie geschrieben ja erstes video
mit face kämen oder so oder alt zeigt
sich oder so und die aber so wie die
folge so die anklage geist jeder andere
ab ins klo oder so und sie zeigen sie
einfach so in deutschland das ist so
krass war nicht übel
ihr könnt jetzt mal in die kommentare
schreiben wie er darauf reagiert hat und
an alle die sagen ja du facebook macht
das nur weil es viel bringt [ __ ] euch
alle
ihr könnt euch gerne mal mit einer
klobürste selbst festen ich mache es
einfach weiß mich wirklich beschäftigt
weil ich wissen was ihr darüber denken
ich will mich jetzt genauso zuschauer
wie ihr auch zuschauer sein
und ja deswegen einfach jetzt könnt ihr
alle idealisten die kommentare zu
schreiben wo ich reifer geschlagen und
merkst nicht bevor die anderen einfach
auch ihre meinung dazu sagen und ja also
mein resümee sozusagen richtig krass
lustig und was ist jetzt für unsere
wahrnehmung von fans bedeutet sagen
jetzt gleich mal aber wie war eigentlich
eure erste reaktion
drauf und ich gucke halt auch ziemlich
aktiv wirksames und wenn euch das
gesehen aber erst nach vertragsschluss
aber erst gar nicht und kann gar nicht
drauf klar passiva hat sich gezeigt
nein
jawoll ist heute das ist mir scheißegal
gerade das mache ich einfach meiner
meinung nach ja wie gesagt sind es hat
mir bescheid gesagt ich habe ein
wirklich dieses video an
dann wollte mich mit dem ts treffen
dachte ja der dir seine komische maske
auf gucke ich meine ich weiter
denn es erzählt dass ich gezeigt habe
dachte ich mir nur so hayward
wenn meine erste reaktion ermöglicht so
dass ich bin da ganz ehrlich dass ich
mit uns geführt
das so gar nicht zu dem image von gttv
passt so hat sich einfach jemand anders
vorgestellt ich find ich sage es
hässlich oder hätte ihn jetzt das ist
gar nicht die frage
jeder mensch kann sehen aussehen wie er
will da hab ich keine vorteile oder so
aber man hat einfach nicht vorgestellt
leider kann ich jeder mensch aus wie wir
will
meiner meinung nach war echt so auch
jetzt mit mir jetzt mal darauf zukommt
was ich davon halte persönlich habe ich
in meine reaktion
ich finde es echt schon krass also man
schaut irgendwie monatelang programms
oder vielleicht auch jahrelang keine
ahnung wie hat ihr dabei seid die jungs
jetzt ja über ein jahr auf youtube also
mindestens mal ein jahr lang könnte man
sich schon geschaut haben und dann
man hat einfach den gesicht dabei und
die stimmen an sich bilden sozusagen das
was man erst als broken fest definiert
das bild von btv genau das ist seltsam
aber die stimmen
wir sind das bild
und dann kommt einfach einfach so
wirklich aus dem nichts
diese face kam rein und man denkt so
machen wir langsam
also ging es um wahnsinnig ich bin mir
also ich hab so ein bisschen hat so ein
bisschen beobachtet er hat ja schon mal
dieses die facebook mit der schweinemast
gemacht und danach kam halt in einem
weiteren video diese andeutung von wegen
ja ich war eine maske kostüm richtig an
die so warm hat er gar keinen bock drauf
und so und da dachte ich mir schon ja
wahrscheinlich kommt demnächst was also
ich habe konnte ich schon so ein
bisschen denken also dort also du hast
du zu entstanden die ratings hat das
demnächst kommt ich wusste nicht in
welchem video aber ich habe grob damit
gerechnet weil erteilt mega darüber
abgekürzt dass ihm die schweinemast
knapp kurz den fans kam aber eigentlich
spaß macht und so und manuel ist gar
nicht so sieht aber und da dachte ja
vielleicht kommt demnächst was wirklich
mit facetime aber man kann es natürlich
nie sagen wollte auch nicht behaupten
jetzt verstehe ich persönlich habe ich
auch was was fällt euch vorgegangen ist
als ich das erste mal eine face gemacht
habe weil ist wirklich schön es ist
schon krass neues wir gehen direkt
weiter an kathi nächste runde
hier oben heil 3 kommt bei 3 schnell
sehr gut perfekt verletzten gekommen
ja und wir haben einfach also ich
verstehe jetzt glaube ich wie es euch
damals ging man sich denkt man kennt
jetzt die stimme und ja man kann
eigentlich nur die stimme man denkt
irgendwie auch wenn es komplett naiv ist
auch wenn es komplett ja vielleicht auch
falsch ist man denkt immer die person
ist die stimme und er sonst nichts mehr
da weil man sich anders kennt oder
bildet jetzt auch so sehen ja bei mir
was zum beispiel mein bestes beispiel
wir haben uns jetzt auch erst vor kurzem
kennengelernt so denkst du ich und man
hat ja auch so ein bild und ja ich will
gar nicht du sieht weiß gar nicht wie
ich aussehe oder ich weiß es nicht
da können wir machen da kann man live
test machen
machen wir jetzt mal wenn wir das machen
laut man avatar im teamspeak und du
reagierst mal drauf damit ist schreien
ist eine seiner meinung nach jetzt
einfach mal live test und schauen jetzt
haben wir im teamspeak hochgeladen so
läuft werden wir wieder fragen wie dumm
abgepackt und deswegen jetzt in der neue
runde es geht in 30 sekunden los aber
fakt geht wie gesagt heute scheiße ich
aufs gameplay einfach nur meine meinung
heute mit euch teilen
und ja natürlich natürlich ist der link
zum video in der beschreibung ich will
auch mein möglichstes tun um den
vielleicht ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit
zu verschaffen im rahmen meiner
möglichkeiten
und ja es hat adobe hatte mir gerade
dieses bild auf intim spiel gezeigt und
ich muss sagen ich hatte mir immer noch
was sie aber bitte was passiert habe ich
gerade gesagt
tobi tut mir leid vorab wissen warum ich
jetzt also wieder habe so wie du bist
mein sowie bester rookie verstanden ja
und was bin ich eigentlich klassisch
hier geplant ist wurde butt lenkt oder
gar keine ahnung was ein baumstamm gar
keine ahnung hatte
baumstämme locker ok hab schon ab schon
auf jeden fall ja ich hab gerade
deutlich niedriger und behindert heilig
gesagt also erst noch relativ normal
aber ja jetzt um auf die alle einander
sache zurückkommen
ich habe mich auch mal komplett anders
vorgestellt er ist aber wirklich so
genial wie so als ich dachte ja auch
einfach mal wenn man es sagen halt nicht
ich dachte einfach so in richtung dena
vielleicht also nicht vom aussehen her
sein so vom typ her und haley sound
beschreiben
ja gut ich ja ich glaub ich verstehen
dass 90 finde ich weiß nicht jetzt also
ich würde schon sagen dass vielleicht
noch einen tick also jetzt um das böse
zu meinen meine persönliche meinung
könnt ihr schreiben wir jetzt anders
findet ich finde dass malta
dann ein tick nötiger aussieht als als
als irina oder so also irgendwann
wichtig gefühl es gibt in der deutschen
die youtuber szene so die wörtliche so
bisheriger aussehen was auch vollkommen
cool ist also wirklich auch kein problem
damit also wirklich das überhaupt kein
problem also wenn jetzt irgendeiner
seite dass es böse gemeint dann fick
dich schlaf ich meine es vollkommen
wertfrei es gibt diese bisherige
aussehen keine ahnung jetzt zum beispiel
malte oder ja um gespielt würde auch
dazu da zu rechnen
da gibt es die reben mit euch zum
beispiel gar nicht so dazu zu ihren
technisch eigentlich der macht auf mich
einen relativ sympathischen und normalen
eindruck so ja aber jetzt habe ich
gerade gesagt das nicht heißt
unsympathisch ja ich meine ja ich weiß
ich weiß aber sagen wir sagen es so dass
die jungs vielleicht ja nicht so nur auf
15 sind so kann man es auch sagen also
vielleicht der hinten auch
außergewöhnlich kaum gespielt natürlich
das erste kriterium was sozusagen das
auge sticht erste merkmal
und ja wir haben da kann man das jetzt
nicht in einer sache aber ich fand's auf
jeden fall nicht überraschend weil wir
auch ein bischen kam geflasht körper
sagen und ich finde aber dass ich glaube
das immer so ist es immer so wenn man so
lange er sich mit so einer person
beschäftigt über personen und man
sozusagen ein bild in seinem kopf
befestigt hat sie fest hat was nur mit
der stimme verknüpft ist und dann in
bild dazu kommt dann also als ein
visuell visuelle eindruck sozusagen
wieder haus mich unterhalte seine dann
ist keiner mehr da ist es ein richtiges
bild von jemandem zu machen denn es ist
quasi unmöglich allein eine andere
stimme so zu sagen was im kopf zu haben
was da mit dem tatsächlichen aus in
dieser person übereinstimmt deswegen
würde ich sagen das kann eigentlich gar
nicht keine ahnung ich glaube es geht
gar nicht und ich glaube dann ist meine
radio kannst grob was denken aber naja
bild vor augen
stimmt schon ich fand es echt wo aber
dann ist es auch wenig gesagt dass
wieder ein problem
teamspeak und schild und kann dieser
frische pizza stetig der vorbei mitten
in den raum und ist einfach er keine
ahnung also ich zu sagen hast du ja dazu
schon jetzt eine meinung gebildet oder
fängt den ersten eindrücken
ich finde ja genau ich weiß nicht ob ich
das schon gesagt habe also ich finde es
wirklich mega kreativ wie brücken
vermisst das umgesetzt hat und der in
der enz auf jeden fall krasse props von
mir extrem und böden aber auch ausreden
hält er erklärt ich nicht erwartet aber
ich finde ich finde schon ungewöhnlich
dass welche ausreden was der hohen so
ein sieger steht auf mir drauf alter das
problem ist die leute nicht auch um spaß
aber es kann sich keiner denken ich
aussehe als ob ich wirklich glaube auch
die leute hätten von ihren ganz falsches
bild komplett kommt komplett
ich weiß nicht ob man es bei mir sagen
kann so von den aufnahmen her weiß nicht
aber bei dir auf jeden fall
scheiße aus leute was sind das für
geräusche das hätte ich mir das wird
irgendwie eine tonne sand runter
geschüttet werden irgendwo ach so ja
okay gut ich habe davor natürlich schon
gespielt aber wusste ich gar nicht
lasst doch ausreden
wir wissen alle wie wir aussehen
ich bin behindert wenn wir schon ewig an
aufgenommen ich war ganz bestimmt für 18
kathrein mache schluss noch mal schreibt
eure reaktion in die kommentare wenn ihr
es wollt und euch das video irgendwie
interessiert hat dann las eine positive
bewertung der kritik in die kommentare
klar aber es hat nicht was die fame
renndistanz behindert und ich hab's
nicht geklärt ist muss ich mir jetzt
gebe ich mir jetzt echt also wie gesagt
ihr müsst was abläuft und dann haut rein
macht's gut und ciao